you know we said last week that the
words regarding recent events would
become action and how about this action
from former teammates in houston deshaun
watson deandre hopkins hopkins now with
the cardinals both went to clemson
clemson was founded chris by the sun and
of the it was founded by the son-in-law
of john c calhoun who was a former vice
president a slave owner and a staunch
and strident defender of slavery hopkins
and watson have come together to urge
clemson to remove calhoun's name from
buildings honors programs streets etc at
clemson university so good for them to
find a way to turn words into action
yeah i mean great leadership and i'm
glad they're doing it i mean this is
stuff that's it's got to be done in our
country it's disrespectful it makes
people feel uncomfortable it's a black
eye in the history of our country i know
you know in the south there's a lot of
conversation always that this is part of
our history all right
then we got it in the history book but
we don't need to throw it into people's
faces where a lot of the meaning is
disrespected horrible stuff for years
and years and years and even me as a
white man mike i don't like to see those
statues or the confederate flag or
anything i don't like what it stands for
so i can't even imagine to put myself in
the shoes of a of a black person
here's what deandre hopkins wrote on
instagram i felt this oppressive figure
during my time at clemson and purposely
do not mention the university's name
before nfl games because of it so that's
how strongly he feels about it and and
you're right it's one thing for us to
see the confederate flag and say what's
the deal there how much worse must it be
for the people who see that as a symbol
of the oppression they've endured
for centuries
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports